thank you again for invitation this is really one of the if not the best meeting i think where i
learned the most from my colleagues uh and other you know members of the overall shared experience
i would say right i want to talk about venous thromboembolism prophylaxis and myeloma and
uh you know what can we do to try to avoid uh losing a single patient in today's day and age
um this is really important because this is the reality we live in right we heard we saw
these slides over the last couple of days you know the i have consistently in years of my
practice avoided talking about cure avoided talking about remission because that was
difficult to achieve right now we have uh long-term uh uh outcomes uh after carditude one
we see that we're finally you know stopped being a curve envy of our lymphoma physicians
and colleagues and then majestic three right i mean you know the last time we had a hazard ratio
like this in my life it was you know the first time we had a hazard ratio like this in my life
my field was never so you know this is the deepest hazard ratio ever produced in early relapse
refractory disease and you know tom spoke well about what is the you know projected median you
know pfs of these regimens 15 to 17 years we're talking about functional cure within few lines
of therapy so a little bit about venous thromboembolism early studies show that
patients are really at high risk of uh vte up to nine times i would say the six months is
erroneous understanding so this is from my loma 11 namely where 90 events occurred during the first
six months you know you'll see the data that hopefully will uh you know convince you that this
is no longer the case uh vt is truly an image related issue i hope i'll also convince you of
that as well uh also in multi-agent chemotherapy alkylators you know vdt pace sometimes when we use
particular combination image we have to really be careful the problem is all the data we have the
little we have lacks any of the data we have the problem is all the data we have the little
risk stratification of crucial importance is the fact that grade 2
events were not even reported but if you look at the grade 2 VT it's actually
indicates some level of management change so therefore we actually have a
severe underestimation of VTE events across the field also things like stroke
things like heart attack are truly related to immunomodulatory drugs and in
my review of literature and AE events in supplementals just across several large
randomized history studies actually indicate the comments like not related
you know and am I how can that not be related to you know therapy when you're
receiving immunomodulatory drug or stroke also you know we showed some of
the data and I'm going to repeat it here you know we analyzed Griffin where VT
incidents was you know 10 to 15 percent depending on the arm so that's really
too high because if you look at the averting Cassini trials that produced
DOAC as a standard of care for venous thromboembolism prophylaxis in
oncology in general the rates were four to five to six percent so you can't
prevent all clotting but you should be able to reduce it down to really single
digits and that's not what we're seeing in myeloma that's a problem there are
different certification systems the key thing is they do not inform about
prophylaxis choice is a very terrible adherence in the community all the large
trials that looked at VT in myeloma or rather in cancer actually barely
included myeloma less than two percent some of them completely excluded myeloma
so we don't really have the data this is the key part what does this matter
because survival is impacted so if you are a VTE patient with newly diagnosed
disease you're predicted to have a lower survival than not and this is after
multivariate analysis so this is not a question of chasing a pro or QL this is
a question of at this day and age breaking even a single egg in a basket
of car teas and by specifics that we're playing with is utterly unacceptable
in my opinion so you know we changed the NCCN guidelines three four years ago you
know provided some input but really quickly I want to run through some of
the data points so this is the Griffin analysis so you can see RVD you know
fifteen point seven sixteen percent VTE so that's too high right that's three
times of what it should be it's a little bit lower in the quadrant but it's also
still elevated the key problem was also the fact that median time to onset was
actually 305 days versus 119 days between these you know quad and triplets
so this really proves to us that this is well problem well beyond six months and
VTE prophylaxis use and adherence was suboptimal and this is telling because
this was a randomized trial this was you know done at academic centers so even
there it's a problem this is the data that represented ask a couple years ago
or ash that we're gonna be publishing very soon but this is really eye-opening
to me this is Maya study so DRD in frontline versus already look at the
incidence of so thromboembolism in general 19% venous thromboembolism 16% so
this is staying consistent right with these regimens the key problem is these
events are actually taking place well beyond two years on therapy and
interestingly PE is actually picking up if you look even more than VTE in terms of DVT points
lower extremity so there's higher incidence of PE later on over the years
when you are on on Revlimid emit containing therapy this is just a
little bit of insight that scoring system such as say that was really
validated has high C static score in terms of predictability actually
performs very poorly to have a safe score of one means that you're low risk
of VTE and as you can see patients with VTE actually had a median score of 1 some of them
even zero and yet they're still catching clots so you know the scores are not really performing
very well this is the data that uh is unpublished yet soon will be but we analyze Lyra and Alcyon
trials you may remember Lyra was a newly diagnosed and a little bit of relapse refractory in the
community there are cyborg D Alcyon was there on VMP we don't really use it in the North American
experience but you know the VTE pardon me the VTE rates here are you know sub sub 10 percent eight
percent five percent seven percent seven percent eight percent seven percent seven percent seven
percent uh with Lyra and actually two percent with Alcyon so this tells us that you know this
has really been driven by immunomodulatory combinations this is our experience from
Vanderbilt which was you know to be honest scary because the rate of VTE was 19 so you
know it's this sort of really tracks uh the the cumulative thromboembolic rates so together with
some arterial events which are around two to three percent consistently across literature you know
it takes us you know to 22 percent so that's really terribly high yeah we had a low adherence
as well um to to VT prophylaxis and then we also did notice that among patients with elevated VTE
risk for those who are on anticoagulation about 18 patients versus who are an aspirin vast majority
of patients there was a a trend towards reduced incidence of VTE so in summary
it's really really preventable I have started giving dogs to my patients about seven years ago I
haven't seen a single VT event in my clinic ever I also thankfully haven't had any bleeding events
anybody that I had to stop the VT prophylaxis on and at this day and age really uh you know having
a patient suffering serious morbidity God forbid mortality is really something that
we should aspire not to ever see thank you foreign